[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm John Helveston,
and thanks for tuning
in my lightning talk on how
to make R-powered surveys with
formr.
If you're someone who has
ever had to make a survey,
chances are, you've
probably used something
like SurveyMonkey
or Google Forms.
And these platforms were
great for simple surveys.
But what if you needed
to make something
that was a little
more complex than what
these platforms offer?
Well, thankfully, some
really clever people
made formr, which uses
R and R Markdown code
to create rich complex surveys.
Now just to be clear, I'm not
one of those clever people.
Formr was actually developed
by Ruben Arslan and Cyril Tata.
I'm just a formr super
fan and I made this talk
to share it with the
rest of the R community
and to demonstrate
some of the cool things
that you can do with it.
So what can formr do?
Well, I kind of think of it like
SurveyMonkey plus R Markdown.
You can use it to
create simple surveys
but you can also use
R code to generate
a much richer set of features.
For example, you could
create interactive charts
that survey respondents
could then experience
while taking the survey.
Or you could use R code to
generate dynamic feedback.
For example, images like this
were generated with ggplot code
for each respondent in a
longitudinal study showing them
their risk preferences for
different activities based
on their answers to
previous questions.
So at this point, you might be
wondering how all this works.
So let's dig into
some of the details.
Surveys in formr are built
using open source components.
The text and code
for each survey
are input using Google Sheets.
And once the survey
is live, R code
is computed using OpenCPU.
This makes it really easy to
make your work as transparent
as you like.
So here's an example,
Google Sheet.
Each row is an item
that will be displayed
on the survey and each column
controls what will be shown.
The label column is where you
insert markdown or code chunks
that you want to
display in the survey.
The type column is where you
set the type of each question
to show.
You can choose from a long list
of options like multiple choice
questions, text entry,
or simply just display
some text or images.
Depending on the
type of question,
you may also have some
options for respondents
that you want them to choose
from like, in a multiple choice
question.
And you can also
customize the look
and feel with some
styling options.
It's analogous to an
R Markdown document,
where the style in question
type columns are like the yaml.
And the label and choice
columns contain the content
that you want to display.
Once you've got your
spreadsheet ready,
you can then log in
to formr.org, input
the link to your
Google Sheet, and formr
will convert it into a survey.
The example I just
showed generates a survey
with some multiple
choice questions
about apples that look
like this in a web browser.
Once your survey's live, you can
then use the associated formr
or package to go import results
in a nicely formatted data
frame directly into R.
Now that we know a little
bit about how formr works,
I'd like to show a
couple of examples of how
I've used it in my own work.
And I'll start with an
example of showing people
randomized images in a
research method known
as conjoint analysis.
In conjoin surveys,
you ask people
to choose from randomized
profiles of different products.
You can then use
that choice data
to estimate their
preferences for attributes
of those products.
So for example, if
I wanted to know
how people felt about
the price or freshness
of different apples, I
could ask them to choose
from profiles like this.
And then in each
choice question,
I'll randomly vary the
values that I'm showing them.
Because I'm working an R, I can
predefine all those profiles
in a data frame.
So in this example, the
three profiles shown
are generated from the first
three rows of this data frame.
I've also used formr to create
timed randomized quizzes
for my class.
I do this by creating
a A and B version
of every question on a quiz.
Then I use the sample
function to randomly select
a version for each question.
In this example,
you might be asked,
what's your favorite animal?
Or what's your favorite
color, depending
on which question is selected.
With just a five
question quiz, I
can generate 32 unique
combinations of quizzes.
And in this particular
example, I've
also added a timer so that
the quiz will automatically
submit when the time is up.
So that's just a few examples
of how I've used formr.
But I encourage you
to check out formr.org
to see some of the
other complex designs
that you might want to make,
like longitudinal or diary
studies with automated email
and text messaging reminders.
Today, over a
million people have
filled out a survey on formr.
And there's a growing user
base with a very active support
group.
So you'll have all the
help you need to build
whatever survey you want.
So head on over to
formr.org and start
making some R-powered surveys.